Jack Frost is on a set record on the
naughty list I wanted to know how
naughty or nice for you as a kid and if
you could be invisible like Jack what
would you do I was a pretty I was a
pretty good kid so I was I would not say
I was on the naughty list that was
pretty determined to get all the good
gifts I could find what was the second
part if you could be invisible like Jack
kids what would you do I don't think
this is that's meant for reportage the
film Jack has to find his sentence so
it's really important for him to find
that hard what do you feel at your
Center is in life why you know my Center
I'm an actor and I love what I do I
think what Santa says in that moment
when he asked Jack what his center is is
to find something that you're passionate
and that you that you love and I
thankfully really blessedly have found
something where I get to live an
extraordinary life and travel meet
really interesting people and be
expressive and and I wouldn't change
that for the world so I I'm content have
you enjoyed me shooting here in London
London's a great city and I remembered
the last time I was here I guess was for
the Star Trek premiere now whatever was
three or four years ago and Leicester
Square I think we were in and it's a
lovely town and the weather's been
fantastic actually yesterday was
beautiful and I could live here right
back in the barnardine
you